The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES W. SWAN: Let's go
ahead and get started.
I hope everybody
saw the correction
to a typo in homework 1 that
was posted on Stellar last night
and sent out to you.
That's going to happen
from time to time.
We have four course staff
that review all the problems.
We try to look through it for
any issues or ambiguities.
But from time to time,
we'll miss something
and try to make a correction.
The TAs gave a hint
that would have let you
solve the problem as written.
But that's more
difficult than what
we had intended for you guys.
We don't want to give you a
homework assignment that's
punishing.
We want to give you
an assignment that'll
help you learn.
Some people in this class that
are very good at programming
have apparently
already completed
that problem with the hint.
But it's easier, as
originally intended.
And the correction resets that.
So maybe you'll
see the distinction
between those things
and understand
why one version of the problem
is much easier than another.
But we try to respond
as quickly as possible
when we notice a typo like
that so that we can set
you guys on the right course.
So we've got two lectures
left discussing linear algebra
before we move on
to other topics.
We're still going to talk about
transformations of matrices.
We looked at one type
of transformation
we could utilize for solving
systems of equations.
Today, we'll look
at another one,
the eigenvalue decomposition.
And on Monday, we'll look at
another one called the singular
value decomposition.
Before jumping right in,
I want to take a minute
and see if there are any
questions that I can answer,
anything that's been
unclear so far that I
can try to reemphasize
or focus on for you.
I was told the office hours
are really well-attended.
So hopefully, you're
getting an opportunity
to ask any pressing questions
during the office hours
or you're meeting
with the instructors
after class to ask
anything that was unclear.
We want to make sure that
we're answering those questions
in a timely fashion.
This course moves at
a pretty quick pace.
We don't want anyone
to get left behind.
Speaking of getting left behind,
we ran out of time a little bit
at the end of
lecture on Wednesday.
That's OK.
There were a lot
of good questions
that came up during class.
And one topic that we
didn't get to discuss
is formal systems
for doing reordering
in systems of equations.
We saw that reordering
is important.
In fact, it's essential for
solving certain problems
via Gaussian elimination.
You won't be able to solve them.
Either you'll incur a
large numerical error
because you didn't
do pivoting-- you'd
like to do pivoting in order to
minimize the numerical error--
or you need to reorder in
order to minimize fill-in.
As an example, I've
solved a research problem
where there was something
like 40 million equations
and unknowns, a system of
partial differential equations.
And if you reorder
those equations,
then you can solve via Gaussian
elimination pretty readily.
But if you don't,
well-- my PC had--
I don't know-- like,
192 gigabytes of RAM.
The elimination on that
matrix will fill the memory
of that PC up in 20 minutes.
And you'll be stuck.
It won't proceed after that.
So it's the difference
between getting a solution
and writing a publication
about the research problem
you're interested in and not.
So how do you do reordering?
Well, we use a process
called permutation.
There's a certain
class of matrix called
a permutation matrix that can--
its action, multiplying
another matrix,
can swap rows or columns.
And here's an example
of a permutation matrix
whose intention is to swap
row 1 and 2 of a matrix.
So here, it looks like
identity, except rather
than having 1, 1 on the first
two elements of the diagonal,
I have 0, 1 and 1, 0.
Here's an example where I take
that sort of a matrix, which
should swap rows 1 and 2, and
I multiply it by a vector.
If you do this matrix
vector multiplication,
you'll see initially, the
vector was x1, x2, x3.
But the product
will be x2, x1, x3.
It swapped two rows
in that vector.
Of course, a vector is
just a matrix, right?
It's an N by 1 matrix.
So P times A is the same
as a matrix whose columns
are P times each of
the columns of A.
That's what this
notation indicates here.
And we know that
P times a vector,
which is the column from A,
will swap two rows in A, right?
So the product here
will be all the rows
of A, the different rows
of AA superscript R,
with row 1 and 2
swapped with each other.
So permutation, multiplication
by the special type
of matrix, a permutation
matrix, does reordering of rows.
If I want to swap columns,
I multiply my matrix
from the right, IP transpose.
So if I want to
swap column 1 and 2,
I multiply A from the
right by P transpose.
How can I show that
that swaps columns?
Well, A times P
transpose is the same
as P times A
transpose transpose.
P swaps rows.
So it's swapping rows
of A transpose, which
is like swapping columns of A.
So we had some
identities associated
with matrix-matrix
multiplication
and their transposes.
And you can use that to work
out how this permutation
matrix will swap
columns instead of rows
if I multiply from the
right instead of the left.
Here's an important
concept to know.
Permutation matrices are-- would
refer to as unitary matrices.
They're transposed.
It's also they're inverse.
So P times P
transpose is identity.
If I swap the rows and
then I swap them back,
I get back what I had before.
So there are lots
of matrices that
have this property
that they're unitary.
We'll see some today.
But permutation matrices are
one class, maybe the simplest
class, of unitary matrices.
They're just doing row
or column swaps, right?
That's their job.
And so if I have some reordering
of the equations or rows
of my system of
equations that I want,
that's going to be indicated by
a permutation matrix-- say, P1.
And I would multiply
my entire system
of-- both sides of my
system of equations by P1.
That would reorder the rows.
If I have some
reordering of the columns
or the unknowns in my problem, I
would use a similar permutation
matrix, P2.
Of course, P2 transpose
times P2 is identity.
So this product
here does nothing
to the system of equations.
It just swaps the unknown.
So there's a formal system for
doing this sort of swapping.
There are a couple other
slides that are in your notes
from last time that
you can look at
and I'm happy to
answer questions on.
We don't have time
to go into detail.
It discusses the actual
methodology, the simplest
possible methodology, for
doing this kind of reordering
or swapping.
So this is a form
of preconditioning.
If it's preconditioning
for pivoting,
it's designed to
minimize numerical error.
If it's preconditioning in order
to minimize fill-in instead,
that's meant to make the problem
solvable on your computer.
But it's a form
of preconditioning
a system of equations.
And we discussed
preconditioning before.
So now we know how to
solve systems of equations.
It's always done via
Gaussian elimination
if we want an exact solution.
There are lots of variants
on Gaussian elimination
that we can utilize.
You're studying one of them
in your homework assignment
now, where you know the matrix
is banded with some bandwidth.
So you don't do elimination
on an entire full matrix.
You do it on a sparse matrix
whose structure you understand.
We discussed sparse
matrices and a little bit
about reordering
and now permutation.
I feel like my diffusion
example last time
wasn't especially clear.
So let me give you a different
example of diffusion.
You guys know Plinko?
Have you seen The
Price Is Right?
This is a game where
you drop a chip
into a board with pegs in it.
It's a model of diffusion.
The Plinko chip falls
from level to level.
It hits a peg.
And it can go left or it can go
right with equal probability.
So the Plinko chip
diffuses as it falls down.
This guy's excited.
[LAUGHTER]
He just won $10,000.
There's a sparse
matrix that describes
how the probability
of finding the Plinko
chip in a certain cell
evolves from level to level.
It works the same way the
cellular automata model
I showed you last time works.
If the chip is in a particular
cell, then at the next level,
there's a 50/50 chance
that I'll go to the left
or I'll go to the right.
It looks like this, right?
If the chip is here, there's
a 50/50 chance I'll go here
or I'll go there.
So if the probability was
1 that I was in this cell,
then at the next level,
it'll be half and a half.
And at the next level, those
halves will split again.
So the probability that I'm in
a particular cell at level i
is this Pi.
And the probability that I'm
in a particular cell level
i plus 1 is this Pi plus one.
And there's some
sparse matrix A which
spreads that probability out.
It splits it into
my neighbors 50/50.
Here's a simulation of Plinko.
So I started with
the probability 1
in the center cell.
And as I go through different
levels, I get split 50/50.
And you see a binomial or almost
Gaussian distribution spread
as I go through
more and more levels
until it's equally probable
that I could wind up
in any one of the cells.
You can think about
it this way, right?
The probability
at level i plus 1
that the chip is in cell
N is inherited 50/50
from its two neighbors, right?
There's some probability that
was in these two neighbors.
I would inherit half
of that probability.
It would be split by these pegs.
The sparse matrix that
represents this operation
has two diagonals.
And on each of those
diagonals is a half.
And you can build that matrix
using the spdiags command.
It says that there's going to
be two diagonal components which
are equal to a half.
And their position
is going to be
one on either side of
the central diagonal.
That's going to indicate that
I pass this probability, 50/50,
to each of my neighbors.
And then successive
multiplications by A
will split this probability.
And we'll see the
simulation that tells us
how probable it is
to find the Plinko
chip in a particular column.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: Yeah.
So in diffusion in general?
AUDIENCE: Well, in this
instance in particular because
[INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: Well, OK.
That's fair enough.
This is one particular model
of the Plinko board, which
sort of imagines alternating
cells that I'm falling through.
We could construct
an alternative model,
if we wanted to, that didn't
have that part of the picture,
OK?
So that's a matrix that
looks like this, right?
The central diagonal is 0.
Most of the
off-diagonal components
here are 0 and 1
above and 1 below.
I get a half and a half.
And if I'm careful--
somebody mentioned
I need boundary conditions.
When the Plinko chip
gets to the edge,
it doesn't fall out of the game.
It gets reflected back in.
So maybe we have to choose some
special values for a couple
of elements of this matrix.
But this is a sparse matrix.
It has a sparse structure.
It models a diffusion problem,
just like we saw before.
Most of physics is
local, like this, right?
I just need to know what's
going on with my neighbors.
And I spread the
probability out.
I get this nice
diffusion problem.
So it looks like this.
Here's something to notice.
After many levels or cycles, I
multiply by A many, many times.
This probability distribution
always seems to flatten out.
It becomes uniform.
It turns out there are even
special distributions for which
A times A times
that distribution is
equal to that distribution.
You can see it at the end here.
This is one of those
special distributions
where the probability is equal
in every other cell, right?
And at the next level,
it all gets passed down.
That's one multiplication by--
it all gets spread by 50%.
And the next
multiplication, everything
gets spread by 50% again.
And I recover the
same distribution
that I had before, this
uniform distribution.
That's a special distribution
for which A times A times P
is equal to P. And
this distribution
is one of the eigenvectors
of this matrix A times A.
It's a particular vector
that when I multiply it
by this matrix AA, I
get that vector back.
It happens to be unstretched.
So this vector points
in some direction.
I transform it by the matrix.
And I get back something that
points in the same direction.
That's the definition of this
thing called an eigenvector.
And this will be the subject
that we focus on today.
So eigenvectors of a matrix--
they're special vectors that
are stretched on multiplication
by the matrix.
So they're transformed.
But they're only transformed
into a stretched form
of whatever they were before.
They point in a direction.
You transform them
by the matrix.
And you get something that
points in the same direction,
but is stretched.
Before, we saw the
amount of stretch.
The previous example, we saw
the amount of stretch was 1.
It wasn't stretched at all.
You just get back the same
vector you had before.
But in principle, it could
come back with any length.
For a real N-by-N
matrix, there will
be eigenvectors and
eigenvalues, which
are the amount of stretch,
which are complex numbers.
And finding
eigenvector-eigenvalue pairs
involves solving N equations.
We'd like to know what
these eigenvectors
and eigenvalues are.
They're non-linear
because they depend
on both the value and the
vector, the product of the two,
for N plus 1 unknowns.
We don't know how to solve
non-linear equations yet.
So we're kind of--
might seem like we're
in a rough spot.
But I'll show you
that we're not.
But because there's N equations
for N plus 1 unknowns,
that means eigenvectors
are not unique.
If W is an eigenvector,
than any other vector
that points in
that same direction
is also an eigenvector, right?
It also gets stretched
by this factor lambda.
So we can never say what
an eigenvector is uniquely.
We can only prescribe
its direction.
Whatever its magnitude
is, we don't care.
We just care about
its direction.
The amount of stretch,
however, is unique.
It's associated
with that direction.
So you have an
amount of stretch.
And you have a direction.
And that describes the
eigenvector-eigenvalue pair.
Is this clear?
You've heard of eigenvalues
and eigenvectors before?
Good.
So how do you find eigenvalues?
They seem like special
sorts of solutions
associated with a matrix.
And if we understood them, then
we can do a transformation.
So I'll explain
that in a minute.
But how do you actually
find these things,
these eigenvalues?
Well, I've got to solve an
equation A times w equals
lambda times w, which can be
transformed into A minus lambda
identity times w equals 0.
And so the solution
set to this equation
is either w is equal to 0.
That's one possible
solution to this problem
or the eigenvector w belongs to
the null space of this matrix.
It's one of those special
vectors that when it multiplies
this matrix gives back 0, right?
It gets projected out on
transformation by this matrix.
Well, this solution doesn't
seem very useful to us, right?
It's trivial.
So let's go with this
idea that w belongs
to the null space
of A minus lambda I.
That means A minus lambda I must
be a singular matrix, whatever
it is, right?
And if it's singular, then the
determinant of a minus lambda
I must be equal to 0.
So if this is true,
and it should be true
if we don't want a
trivial solution, then
the determinant of A minus
lambda I is equal to 0.
So if we can compute
that determinant
and solve for lambda, then
we'll know the eigenvalue.
Well, it turns out that
the determinant of a matrix
like A minus lambda I is a
polynomial in terms of lambda.
It's a polynomial
of degree N called
the characteristic polynomial.
And the N roots of this
characteristic polynomial
are called the
eigenvalues of the matrix.
So there are N possible
lambdas for which A minus
lambda I become singular.
It has a null space.
And associated with those
values are eigenvectors, vectors
that live in that null space.
So this polynomial-- we could
compute it for any matrix.
We could compute this
thing in principle, right?
And we might even be able
to factor it into this form.
And then lambda 1,
lambda 2, lambda N
in this factorized form are
all the possible eigenvalues
associated with our
matrix A, right?
There are all the possible
amounts of stretch
that can be imparted to
particular eigenvectors.
We don't know those
vectors yet, right?
We'll find them in a second.
But we know the
amounts of stretch
that can be imparted
by this matrix.
OK?
Any questions so far?
No.
Let's do an example.
Here's a matrix, minus 2, 1, 3.
And it's 0's everywhere else.
And we'd like to find the
eigenvalues of this matrix.
So we need to know A minus
lambda I and its determinant.
So here's A minus lambda
I. We just subtract lambda
from each of the diagonals.
And the determinant--
well, here, it's
just the product of
the diagonal elements.
So that's the determinant
of a diagonal matrix
like this, the product
of the diagonal elements.
So it's minus 2 minus lambda
times 1 minus lambda times 3
minus lambda.
And the determent of this
has to be equal to 0.
So the amounts of
stretch, the eigenvalues
imparted by this matrix,
are minus 2, 1, and 3.
And we found the eigenvalues.
Here's another matrix.
Can you work out the
eigenvalues of this matrix?
Let's take 90 seconds.
You can work with
your neighbors.
See if you can figure out the
eigenvalues of that matrix.
Nobody's collaborating today.
I'm going to do it myself.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: It's OK.
OK.
What are you finding?
Anyone want to guess
what are the eigenvalues?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: Good.
OK.
So we need to compute the
determinant of A minus lambda
I. That'll be minus 2
minus lambda times minus 2
minus lambda minus 1.
You can solve this to find that
lambda equals minus 3 or minus
1.
These little checks are useful.
If you couldn't do
this, that's OK.
But you should try to
practice this on your own
to make sure you can.
Here are some more examples.
So the elements of
a diagonal matrix
are always the eigenvalues
because the determinant
of a diagonal matrix
is the product
of the diagonal elements.
So these diagonal values here
are the roots of the secular
characteristic polynomial.
They are the eigenvalues.
It turns out the diagonal
elements of a triangular matrix
are eigenvalues, too.
This should seem
familiar to you.
We talked about easy-to-solve
systems of equations, right?
Diagonal systems of equations
are easy to solve, right?
Triangular systems of
equations are easy to solve.
It's also easy to find
their eigenvalues.
So the diagonal elements
here are the eigenvalues
of the triangular matrix.
And eigenvalues have
certain properties
that can be inferred from the
properties of polynomials,
right?
Since they are the
roots to a polynomial,
if we know certain
things that should
be true of those
polynomial of roots,
that has to be true of the
eigenvalues themselves.
So if we have a matrix
which is real-valued,
then we know that
we're going to have
this polynomial of degree N
which is also real-valued, OK?
It can have no more
than N roots, right?
And so A can have no more
than N distinct eigenvalues.
The eigenvalues, like the
factors of the polynomial,
don't have to be
distinct, though?
You could have multiplicity in
the roots of the polynomial.
So it's possible that lambda
1 here is an eigenvalue twice.
That's referred to as
algebraic multiplicity.
We'll come back to
that idea in a second.
Because the polynomial
is real-valued,
it means that the
eigenvalues could
be real or complex,
just like the roots
of a real-valued polynomial.
But complex eigenvalues always
appear as conjugate pairs.
If there is a
complex eigenvalue,
then necessarily its
complex conjugate
is also an eigenvalue.
And here's a couple
other properties.
So the determinant
of a matrix is
the product of the eigenvalues.
We talked once about the
trace of a matrix, which
is the sum of its
diagonal elements.
The trace of a matrix is also
the sum of the eigenvalues.
These can sometimes
come in handy--
not often, but sometimes.
Here's an example I
talked about before--
so a series of
chemical reactions.
So we have a batch,
a batch reactor.
We load some material in.
And we want to know how the
concentrations of A, B, C,
and D vary as a
function of time.
And so A transforms into B.
B and C are in equilibrium.
C and D are in equilibrium.
And our conservation equation
for material is here.
This is a rate matrix.
We'd like to understand what
the characteristic polynomial
of that is.
The eigenvalues
of that matrix are
going to tell us something
about how different rate
processes evolve in time.
You can imagine
just using units.
On this side, we have
concentration over time.
On this side, we
have concentration.
And the rate matrix has units
of rate, or 1 over time.
So those eigenvalues
also have units of rate.
And they tell us the rate at
which different transformations
between these materials occur.
And so if we want to find
the characteristic polynomial
of this matrix and we need to
compute the determinant of this
matrix minus lambda I-- so
subtract lambda from each
of the diagonals--
even though this is a
four-by-four matrix,
its determinant
is easy to compute
because it's full of zeros.
I'm not going to
compute it for you here.
It'll turn out that the
characteristic polynomial looks
like this.
You should actually try
to do this determinant
and show that the polynomial
works out to be this.
But knowing that this is the
characteristic polynomial,
what are the eigenvalues
of the rate matrix?
If that's the
characteristic polynomial,
what are the
eigenvalues, or tell me
some of the eigenvalues
of the rate matrix?
AUDIENCE: 0.
JAMES W. SWAN: 0.
0's an eigenvalue.
Lambda equals 0 is a solution.
Minus k1 is another solution.
What is this eigenvalue
0 correspond to?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: OK.
Physically, it's a rate process
with 0 rate, steady state.
So the 0 eigenvalue's going to
correspond to the steady state.
The eigenvector associated
with that eigenvalue
should correspond to the
steady state solution.
How about this
eigenvalue minus k1?
This is a rate
process with rate k1.
What physical process
does that represent?
It's something evolving
in time now, right?
So that's the
transformation of A into B.
And the eigenvector should
reflect that transformation.
We'll see what those
eigenvectors are in a minute.
But these eigenvalues
can be interpreted
in terms of physical processes.
This quadratic solution
here has some eigenvalue.
I don't know what it is.
You use the quadratic
formula and you can find it.
But it involves k2, k3, k4.
And this is a typo.
It should be k5.
And so that says something about
the interconversion between B,
C, and D, and the rate
processes that occur
as we convert from B to C to D.
Is that too fast?
Do you want to write some more
on this slide before I go on,
or are you OK?
Are there any
questions about this?
No.
Given an eigenvalue, a
particular eigenvalue, what's
the corresponding eigenvector?
We know the eigenvector
isn't uniquely specified.
It belongs to the null
space of this matrix
A minus lambda I times identity.
Even though it's not
unique, we might still
try to find it using
Gaussian elimination, right?
So we may try to take--
we may try to solve the
equation A minus lambda
I times identity
multiplied by w equals
0 using Gaussian elimination.
But because it's not
unique, at some point,
we'll run out of rows
to eliminate, right?
There's a null space
to this matrix, right?
We won't be able to
eliminate everything.
We'd say it's rank
deficient, right?
So we'll be able to
eliminate up to some R,
the rank of this matrix.
And then all the
components below
are essentially free or
arbitrarily specified.
There are no
equations to say what
those components of
the eigenvector are.
The number of all 0 rows--
it's called the geometric
multiplicity of the eigenvalue.
Sorry.
Geometric is missing here.
It's the number of components
of the eigenvector that
can be freely specified.
The geometric
multiplicity might be 1.
That's like saying that
the eigenvectors are all
pointing in the same
direction, but can have
arbitrary magnitude, right?
It might have geometric
multiplicity 2, which
means the eigenvectors
associated with this eigenvalue
live in some plane.
And any vector from that plane
is a corresponding eigenvector.
It might have a higher geometric
multiplicity associated
with it.
So let's try something here.
Let's try to find the
eigenvectors of this matrix.
I told you what the
eigenvalues were.
They were the
diagonal values here.
So they're minus 2, 1, and 3.
Let's look for the
eigenvector corresponding
to this eigenvalue.
So I want to solve this equation
A minus this particular lambda,
which is minus 2, times
identity equals 0.
So I got to do Gaussian
elimination on this matrix.
It's already eliminated
for me, right?
I have one row which
is all 0's, which
says the first component
of my eigenvector
can be freely specified.
The other two
components have to be 0.
3 times the second component
of my eigenvector is 0.
5 times the third
component is 0.
So the other two
components have to be 0.
But the first component
is freely specified.
So the eigenvector associated
with this eigenvalue
is 1, 0, 0.
If I take a vector which
points in the x-direction in R3
and I multiply it
by this matrix,
it gets stretched by minus 2.
So I point in the
other direction.
And I stretch out
by a factor of 2.
You can guess then what
the other eigenvectors are.
What's the eigenvector
associated with this eigenvalue
here?
0, 1, 0, or anything
proportional to that.
What's the
eigenvector associated
with this eigenvalue?
0, 0, 1, or anything
proportional to it.
All these eigenvectors have a
geometric multiplicity of 1,
right?
I can just specify some
scalar variant on them.
And they'll transform
into themselves.
Here's a problem you can try.
Here's our series of
chemical reactions again.
And we want to know the
eigenvector of the rate
matrix having eigenvalue 0.
This should correspond
to the steady state
solution of our ordinary
differential equation here.
So you've got to do
elimination on this matrix.
Can you do that?
Can you find this eigenvector?
Try it out with your neighbor.
See if you can do it.
And then we'll compare results.
This will just be a quick
test of understanding.
Are you guys able to do this?
Sort of, maybe?
Here's the answer, or an
answer, for the eigenvector.
It's not unique, right?
It's got some constant
out in front of it.
So you do Gaussian
elimination here.
So subtract or add the
first row to the second row.
You'll eliminate this 0, right?
And then add the second
row to the third row.
You'll eliminate this k2.
You have to do a little bit more
work to do elimination of k4
here.
But that's not a big deal.
Again, you'll add the
third row to the fourth row
and eliminate that.
And you'll also wind
up eliminating this k5.
So the last row here
will be all 0's.
And that means the last
component of our eigenvector's
freely specifiable.
It can be anything we want.
So I said it is 1.
And then I did back
substitution to determine all
the other components, right?
That's the way to do this.
And here's what the eigenvector
looks like when you're done.
The steady state
solution has no A in it.
Of course, A is just eliminated
by a forward reaction.
So if we let this run out to
infinity, there should be no A.
And that's what happens.
But there's equilibria
between B, C, and D.
And the steady state solution
reflects that equilibria.
We have to pick what this
constant out in front is.
And we discussed this
before, actually, right?
You would pick that based on
how much material was initially
in the reactor.
We've got to have an
overall mass balance.
And that's missing from this
system of equations, right?
Mass conservation is what gave
the null space for this rate
matrix in the first place.
Make sense?
Try this example out.
See if you can work
through the details of it.
I think it's useful to be able
to do these sorts of things
quickly.
Here are some simpler problems.
So here's a matrix.
It's not a very good matrix.
Matrices can't be good or bad.
It's not particularly
interesting.
But it's all 0's.
So what are its eigenvalues?
It's just 0, right?
The diagonal elements
are the eigenvalues.
And they're 0.
That eigenvalue has
algebraic multiplicity 2.
It's a double root of the
secular characteristic
polynomial.
Can you give me
the eigenvectors?
eigenvectors of this matrix?
Can you give me linearly
independent-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES W. SWAN: OK.
Good.
So this is a very ambiguous sort
of problem or question, right?
Any vector I multiply by A here
is going to be stretched by 0
because A by its very
nature is all 0's.
All those vectors
live in a plane.
So any vector from
that plane is going
to be transformed in this way.
The eigenvector
corresponding to eigenvalue 0
has geometric multiplicity
2 because I can freely
specify two of its components.
Oh my goodness.
I went so fast.
We'll just do it this way.
Algebraic multiplicity 2,
geometric multiplicity 2--
I can pick two vectors.
They can be any two I
want in principle, right?
It has geometric multiplicity 2.
Here's another matrix.
It's a little more
interesting than the last one.
I stuck a 1 in there instead.
Again, the eigenvalues are 0.
It's a double root.
So it has algebraic
multiplicity 2.
But you can convince
yourself that there's
only one direction
that transforms
that squeeze down to 0, right?
There's only one
vector direction
that lives in the null
space of A minus lambda I--
lives in the null
space of A. And that's
vectors parallel to 1, 0.
So the eigenvector associated
with that eigenvalue 0
has geometric
multiplicity 1 instead
of geometric multiplicity 2.
Now, here's an
example for you to do.
Can you find the eigenvalues
and some linearly independent
eigenvectors of this
matrix, which looks
like the one we just looked at.
But now it's three-by-three
instead of two-by-two.
And if you find those
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
what are the algebraic and
geometric multiplicity?
Well, you guys must
had a rough week.
You're usually
much more talkative
and energetic than this.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, what are the
eigenvalues here?
AUDIENCE: 0.
JAMES W. SWAN: Yeah.
They all turn out to be 0.
So that's an algebraic
multiplicity of 3.
It'll turn out there are two
vectors, two vector directions,
that I can specify that will
both be squeezed down to 0.
In fact, any vector
from the x-y plane
will also be squeezed down to 0.
So this has algebraic
multiplicity 3 and geometric
multiplicity 2.
I'm going to explain why this
is important in a second.
But understanding
that this can happen
is going to be useful for you.
So if an eigenvalue
is distinct, then it
has algebraic multiplicity 1.
It's the only eigenvalue
with that value.
It's the only time that
amount of stretch is imparted.
And there will be only one
corresponding eigenvector.
There will be a direction
and an amount of stretch.
If an eigenvalue has a
algebraic multiplicity M,
well, you just saw that
the geometric multiplicity,
which is the dimension of
the null space of A minus
lambda I--
it's the dimension
of the space spanned
by no vectors of
A minus lambda I--
it's going to be bigger
than 1 or equal to 1.
And it's going to be
smaller or equal to M.
And we saw different variants on
values that sit in this range.
So there could be as many
as M linearly independent
eigenvectors.
And there may be fewer.
So geometric multiplicity--
it's the number
of linearly independent
eigenvectors associated
with an eigenvalue.
It's the dimension of the
null space of this matrix.
Problems for which the geometric
and algebraic multiplicity
are the same for all the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
all those pairs, are nice
because the matrix then
is said to have a complete
set of eigenvectors.
There's enough
eigenvectors in the problem
that they describe the
span of our vector space
RN that our matrix is doing
transformations between.
If we have geometric
multiplicity that's
smaller than the
algebraic multiplicity,
then some of these
stretched-- we
can't stretch in all
possible directions in RN.
There's going to be a direction
that might be left out.
We want to be able to do
a type of transformation
called an eigendecomposition.
I'm going to show
you that in a second.
It's useful for solving
systems of equations
or for transforming systems
of ordinary differential
equations, linear ordinary
differential equations.
But we're only going to
be able to do that when
we have this complete
set of eigenvectors.
When we don't have
that complete set,
we're going to have to do
other sorts of transformations.
You have a problem in your
homework now, I think,
that has this sort of a
hang-up associated with it.
It's the second problem
in your homework set.
That's something to think about.
For a matrix with the
complete set of eigenvectors,
we can write the following.
A times a matrix W is equal
to W times the matrix lambda.
Let me tell you what
W and lambda are.
So W's a matrix whose
columns are made up of this--
all of these eigenvectors.
And lambda's a matrix
whose diagonal values are
each of the corresponding
eigenvalues associated
with those eigenvectors.
This is nothing more
than a restatement
of the original
eigenvalue problem.
AW is lambda W. But
now each eigenvalue
has a corresponding
particular eigenvector.
And we've stacked
those equations up
to make this statement about
matrix-matrix multiplication.
So we've taken each of
these W's over here.
And we've just made them the
columns of a particular matrix.
But it's nothing more
than a restatement
of the fundamental
eigenvalue problem
we posed at the beginning here.
But what's nice is if I
have this complete set
of eigenvectors, then W has an
inverse that I can write down.
So another way to state this
same equation is that lambda--
the eigenvalues can be found
from this matrix product, W
inverse times A times W.
And under these
circumstances, we
say the matrix can
be diagonalized.
There's a transformation
from A to a diagonal form.
That's good for us, right?
We know diagonal systems of
equations are easy to solve,
right?
So if I knew what the
eigenvectors were,
then I can transform my
equation to this diagonal form.
I could solve systems of
equations really easily.
Of course, we just
saw that knowing
what those eigenvectors
are requires solving
systems of equations, anyway.
So the problem of
finding the eigenvectors
is as hard as the problem of
solving a system of equations.
But in principle, I can do
this sort of transformation.
Equivalently, the matrix A can
be written as W times lambda
times W inverse.
These are all equivalent
ways of writing
this fundamental relationship
up here when the inverse of W
exists.
So this means that if I know the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
I can easily reconstruct
my equation, right?
If I know the
eigenvectors in A, then I
can easily diagonalize my
system of equations, right?
So this is a useful sort
of transformation to do.
We haven't talked about how
it's done in the computer.
We've talked about how
you would do it by hand.
These are ways you
could do it by hand.
The computer won't do
Gaussian elimination
for each of those eigenvectors
independently, right?
Each elimination procedure
is order N cubed, right?
And you got to do that
for N eigenvectors.
So that's N to the
fourth operations.
That's pretty slow.
There's an alternative
way of doing it
that's beyond the scope
of this class called--
it's called the
Lanczos algorithm.
And it's what's referred
to as a Krylov subspace
method, that sort
of iterative method
where you take products of your
matrix with certain vectors
and from those products,
infer what the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues are.
So that's the way a
computer's going to do it.
That's going to be an order
N cubed sort of calculation
to find all the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors [INAUDIBLE]
solving a system of equations.
But sometimes you
want these things.
Here's an example of how
this eigendecomposition can
be useful to you if you did it.
So we know the matrix A can
be represented as W lambda W
inverse times x equals b.
This is our transformed
system of equations here.
We've just substituted for A.
If I multiply both sides of
this equation by W inverse,
then I've got lambda times
the quantity W inverse x
is equal to W inverse b.
And if I call this
quantity in parentheses y,
then I have an easy-to-solve
system of equations for y.
y is equal to lambda
inverse times c.
But lambda inverse
is just 1 over each
of the diagonal
components of lambda.
Lambda's a diagonal matrix.
Then all I need
to do-- ooh, typo.
There's an equal
sign missing here.
Sorry for that.
Now all I need to do is
substitute for what I called y
and what I called c.
So y was W inverse times x.
That's equal to lambda inverse
times W inverse times b.
And so I multiply both sides of
this equation by W. And I get x
is W lambda inverse W inverse b.
So if I knew the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors,
I can really easily solve
the system of equations.
If I did this decomposition,
I could solve many systems
of equations, right?
They're simple to
solve with just
matrix-matrix multiplication.
Now, how is W inverse computed?
Well, W inverse transpose
are actually the eigenvectors
of A transpose.
You may have to compute
this matrix explicitly.
But there are times
when we deal with
so-called symmetric
matrices, ones for which they
are equal to their transpose.
And if that's the
case, and if you
take all of your eigenvectors
and you normalize them
so they're of length 1--
the Euclidean norm is 1--
then it'll turn out that
W inverse is precisely
equal to W transpose, right?
And so the eigenvalue
matrix will be unitary.
It'll have this property where
its transposes is its inverse,
right?
So this becomes
trivial to do then,
this process of W inverse.
It's not always true that
this is the case, right?
It is true when we
deal with problems
that have symmetric matrices
associated with them.
That pops up in a lot of cases.
You can prove--
I might ask you to
show this some time--
that the eigenvectors
of a symmetric matrix
are orthogonal, that they
satisfy this property that--
I take the dot product between
two different eigenvectors
and it'll be equal to 0 unless
those are the same eigenvector.
That's a property associated
with symmetric matrices.
They're also useful
when analyzing
systems of ordinary
differential equations.
So here, I've got a differential
equation, a vector x dot.
So the time derivative of
x is equal to A times x.
And if I substitute my
eigendecomposition--
so W lambda W inverse--
and I define a new
unknown y instead of x,
then I can diagonalize
that system of equations.
So you see y dot is
equal to lambda times y
where each component
of y is decoupled
from all of the others.
Each of them satisfies their own
ordinary differential equation
that's not coupled to
any of the others, right?
And it has a simple
first-order rate constant,
which is the
eigenvalue associated
with that particular
eigendirection.
So this system of
ODEs is decoupled.
And it's easy to solve.
You know the solution, right?
It's an exponential.
And that can be quite
handy when we're
looking at different sorts
of chemical rate processes
that correspond to linear
differential equations.
We'll talk about nonlinear,
systems of nonlinear,
differential equations
later in this term.
And you'll find out that
this same sort of analysis
can be quite useful there.
So we'll linearize
those equations.
And we'll ask is their linear--
in their linearized form, what
are these different
rate constants?
How big are they?
They might determine
what we need
to do in order to integrate
those equations numerically
because there are many
times when there's not
a complete set of eigenvectors.
That happens.
And then the matrix can't
be diagonalized in this way.
There are some
components that can't
be decoupled from each other.
That's what this
diagonalization does, right?
It splits up these different
stretching directions
from each other.
But there's some directions
that can't be decoupled
from each other anymore.
And then there are other
transformations one can do.
So there's an
almost diagonal form
that you can transform into
called the Jordan normal form.
There are other transformations
that one can do, like called,
for example, Schur
decomposition, which
is a transformation
into an upper triangular
form for this matrix.
We'll talk next time about the
singular value decomposition,
which is another sort
of transformation one
can do when we don't have these
complete sets of eigenvectors.
But this concludes our
discussion of eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
You'll get a chance to practice
these things on your next two
homework assignments, actually.
So it'll come up in a couple
of different circumstances.
I would really
encourage you to try
to solve some of these example
problems that were in here.
Solving by hand can be useful.
Make sure you can
work through the steps
and understand where these
different concepts come
into play in terms
of determining
what the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors are.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
See you on Monday.